you claimed infinite banking concept was
a scam and actually got quite pissed off
about it I um do not agree with that in
certain points that you made in that um
video and I have set up a policy for my
son uh when he was one years old he's
five now um has a
$500,000 face value we pay $
5,373 a year for 13 years and it's paid
up at that point point so you claim that
uh the cash value dies with you and you
only get um the face value of paid out
that's true that is well it's not true
if you reinvest the dividends back into
the policy dividend reinvestment is not
cash
value dividend reinvestment is because
you have a mutual company and the policy
holders are the owners of the company
and so the profits from the company come
to the policy holder